one of mexico's most iconic species the
monarch butterfly has just lost perhaps
its greatest advocate
in michoacan foreign
if we were to analyze omero's death he
was saying things that perhaps other
people didn't want to listen to and he
was also dealing with people linked to
organized crime romero gomez the manager
of the sanctuary was found dead after
police say he was beaten and thrown down
a well his family says he had recently
received threats warning him to stop the
campaign against illegal logging
because the police investigation has
been so opaque and because people are so
fearful to speak and tell journalists
the truth because of the kind of society
of fear which has been created around
speaking truth to power then it is
likely that we might not ever know why
omero ended up in irrigation ditch in
late january 2020
[Music]
the monarch butterfly migration is one
of the most impressive natural phenomena
in the world
every year swarms of black and orange
colored butterflies about the size of a
small kind of saucer travel 2
500 miles from north america canada area
all the way to the forest of central
mexico
[Music]
the rosario sanctuary with the story
sort of takes place is in the state of
michoacan it's a protected area with
tremendous amounts of woodland mainly
pine
it's a very beautiful and very sort of
singular area within mexico
geographically and biologically speaking
romero was a local to the area to legit
rosario which is in michoacan
he grew up with the monarchs and
actually his grandparents often told him
that the monarchs were effectively the
spirits of his ancestors
[Music]
my name is valencia
de la comunidad de san luis municipal
michoacan
when you've got an area like a biosphere
which is obviously a very fertile place
where there are lots of natural
resources you have all sorts of
conflicts so you have people that want
to use
the trees for logging you know both
legal and illegal
when there's so much money at stake and
there's all this land which could be
used then yes there are conflicting
interests
omero and his family worked in the
timber industry and the local
environment which they inhabited was
their biggest economic resource so when
the biosphere was formed or certain
parts of it protected over the years
omero wasn't necessarily in favor
however as the international community
came in and the scientists were sort of
observing this natural phenomenon which
is an incredible thing to witness
i think he began to see the butterfly as
something extremely important and a way
that could not only preserve the way of
life that he had become used to in the
community but was something that was of
national international importance he
then became one of the biggest advocates
and became an extremely important figure
both nationally and internationally for
the protection and the diffusion of the
story of the monarch butterfly in mexico
and abroad
he was a larger-than-life person there's
a spanish expression called donde gentes
which is like a person who really has
you know a way with people you know he
could he was charismatic charming and he
was the type of person if they went to a
local event all the local politicians
would know him
he really was an advocate for the
butterfly and worked extremely hard to
tell their story he wouldn't take no for
an answer
i think he rubbed up a lot of local
politicians the wrong way as well as the
local scientists he had friends in
powerful places as well and i think that
was just the nature of his job when one
wants to
rise to become a public figure in mexico
and one is willing to criticize people
openly or even not criticize but sort of
fight against
certain aims
then he or she puts himself at risk the
southwest state of michoacan is where
mexico's drug war began
michoacan state where the story took
place is probably one of the most
dangerous states in mexico at present
that's lots of drug routes it's full of
natural resources and also it is the
epicenter for the avocado trade
what's happening now in mexico is very
interesting
cartels are moving towards almost
legitimizing themselves in a way so
they're moving into ordinary businesses
and they're moving into things like
avocado trade which is an incredibly
lucrative trade worth about 2.4 billion
dollars annually and 80
of the avocados that are imported in the
united states come from mexico itself
the cartels will come in and use
physical violence wipe farmers off their
land take over the land and therefore
infiltrate themselves into the trade
there's almost like a civil war between
the drug cartels in michogan state so
everyone's fighting for the drug
smuggling roots the avocado trade the
natural resources and what happens when
you exist in a state in which the
authorities are corruptable it's very
easy to infiltrate these areas and
you've seen that a lot in the western
part of the state where the tactics have
almost become medieval people hanging
from bridges massacres kidnappings of
big avocado farmers just because there's
so much money at play
where the sanctuary itself is situated
is further to the east so it's near the
state of mexico closer to mexico city
itself and that area isn't too affected
by organized crime but even so the kind
of the shadow the looming nature of
organized crime
means that people are always wary of
talking to outsiders
romero's wife rebecca lived in a
constant state of fear because she knew
where she lived and she said that she
would often tell him please be careful
and he said no no these people are my
friends
around midday on january 13th omero
gomez attended what would be his last
meeting
it was an ordinary meeting it was to
take place in the butterfly sanctuary el
rosario
[Music]
the only thing that people really
remember from that meeting in fact is
that omero himself was receiving
constant phone calls his phone was
buzzing constantly constantly constantly
according to some of the people who
attended that meeting he eventually
picked up the phone and the other person
on the other end of the line um was
trying to convince him to go to
a local event in a town called el
soldado where there was like a local
kind of fare
i think there was horse racing drinking
eating a local kind of party where a lot
of the local politicians would be
activists you know people that omeron
normally kind of hung around with so to
speak and he arrived according to his
family and to other people that attended
the event and then soledad around about
4 5 pm
there he met with local politicians and
they described him as being
kind of normal his normal charismatic
self
and then it was around about 7 8 p.m
that one of the politicians that i spoke
to who's at the event saw him for the
last time
obviously people became very worried
because in mexico someone goes missing
um then it's obviously a bad sign and
that's when his wife particularly began
to worry because she knew very well the
types of people that omero hung around
with who he dealt with
the next day they reported it to the
police the police said that they would
take it very seriously because he was a
public person within you know a matter
of days search parties were formed
in which the family took part in the
national police local police i think
even the federal police actually helped
in these searches
another
the days went on and the search party
searched kept searching kept searching
kept searching and nothing was found
that was until the 29th of january
when a local shepherd
found
the body of omero gomez in an irrigation
ditch which was about 150 meters from
where the local fare had been taking
place
one of the search brigades had searched
that area about a week before and they'd
found absolutely nothing omer's son told
me that people had even thrown stones
down into the irrigation ditch to check
to see if there was anything there
[Music]
personally
amigos
and while the police kind of kept quiet
about this that led a lot of people to
suspect that the body had been
put there after the fact
when the police came out and um offered
their official statement on the case
they said that the body had received
blunt head trauma and had been strangled
or asphyxiated
um however they weren't willing to say
definitively that this had been a murder
it could have been an accident while the
family weren't obviously willing to
believe this omero jr himself told me on
many occasions that he thinks his father
was murdered
i regularly check in with the family and
they say that there's been no update in
the case that no one really has been in
contact with them that the police
seemingly have
sort of forgotten
being an activist is a very dangerous
thing to be
quite a few activists in the last few
years have been murdered for the message
that they're trying to spread in the
same way that journalists they are often
murdered for trying to do their job or
having become involved in corruption and
i think what that says about the state
is that if you want to speak out against
power or list activities it's one of the
most dangerous things that you can do
because the police investigation has
been so opaque and because people are so
fearful to speak and tell journalists
the truth then it is likely that we
might not ever know why he ended up in
an irrigation ditch in late january 2020
[Music]
[Music]
you